hello lovely people I'm Alana welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another episode of good gaming news
which is a weekly ish gaming news show
where I talk about all the good stuff
that happens in gaming because there are
enough people out there covering
negative stuff I want to spread some
positivity I skipped last week just
because with Ragnarok coming out it was
a very busy week for me
um but we're here we're good to go the
first story is one that I'm super
excited about that I think I didn't
expect weirdly this really caught me off
guard especially the timing of the
announcement this says the sequel to
control a remedy entertainment signs a
co-development and co-publishing
agreement with 505 games for control two
essentially control 2 has been announced
played a fair amount of control when did
all the optional bosses and everything
and um there are things that I really
love about it some things I wasn't so
hard on but one thing that I am certain
of is that I am happy to have more of
this very potent remedy weirdness in the
video game space I mean I'm also just
extremely glad that we're getting a new
Alan Wake and it's survival horror but
getting both let's go baby it's a really
unique game a really unique world that
definitely left me with more questions
than answers I think ultimately even
though that last chapter was awesome so
I'm totally down to Seymour so the story
from remedygames.com says remedy
entertainment and 505 games have signed
an agreement under which they will
co-develop and co-publish control 2
formerly known as codename Heron a
sequel to the award-winning game control
for more details refer to our investor
website don't mind if I do read on for a
message on control too from Mikhail
kasurinen game director of the control
franchise oh this is some control 2
concept art
it looks a little like control one to be
honest he said with control we leaped
into the unknown we wanted to create
something new something different and
unexpected a world like no other thank
you the audience for making control such
a success for us with control 2 we'll
take another leap into the unknown it'll
be an Unexpected Journey it'll take a
while but to put it mildly this is the
most exciting project I've ever worked
on it's still early days but it will be
worth the wait
and obviously this was announced for
investors more than anything that's why
they announced it so far ahead I imagine
that 505 wanted it to be public as well
this is almost definitely an agreement
that they were like well we need to let
the investors know so it's going to leak
so let's just announce it anyway not
that it's really a leak updating your
investors is effectively updating the
public but sometimes you need to have a
certain portfolio public to make sure
that people continue to invest and you
do better on the stock market if you're
a publicly traded company and I only
mentioned that to um preempt the Aya of
Gamers who are upset when companies
announce things too early it's because
they didn't announce it for you so this
is the investor site
investors.remitygames.com which says
remedy entertainment signs a
co-development and co-publishing
agreement with fiber 5 games for control
too remedy entertainment remedy
allegedly has signed an agreement in 505
games an international video game
publisher and a subsidiary of digital
Bros group under which remedy and 505
games will co-develop and co-publish
control 2 formerly known as codename
Heron a sequel to remedies of
one-winning game control control 2's
initial development budget amounts to to
Euro 50 million is that a lot it's 50
million euros okay they're a lot closer
in currency than I thought and I believe
the original control was like around 30
million or just under 30 million uh
remedy will retain ownership of the
game's intellectual property which is
always awesome news and can be very very
difficult to bargain for so Props to
remedy for being able to do that the
development marketing and post-launch
Investments as well as the future net
revenues generated by the game will be
split equally between 505 and remedy the
game will be available on PC PlayStation
5 and Xbox series Xs and it will be
built on remedies proprietary North
light engine and tools Ray tracing baby
let's go remedy will publish the game on
the PC platform and 505 games will
publish it on Console platforms that
make sense the project is currently in
the concept stage which is
pre-pre-production which generally means
that they haven't even started working
on some characters may exist in some
gray boxes but the game doesn't really
exist since its launch in 2019 control
has sold over 3 million copies say Rami
and Rafi galantes co-ceos of digital
Bros group 505 game it all also says in
June 2021 remedy announced that the
company had outlined high-level
collaboration terms with 505 games for a
bigger budget control game I'm now proud
to confirm that the bigger budget
control game also known as codename
Heron is controlled to a full-blown
sequel to our award-winning game control
I guess that's the confirmation that
it's a sequel obviously that screenshot
looked very similar but it didn't
necessarily need to be a sequel does
that mean that it's going to be direct
she's the director the agreement does
not have an impact on remedies outlook
for 2022. this is probably just the same
concept art yeah that's all we've got so
far
which really again is pretty damn
similar to the first game the concept
art is outdoors I think that's what
we're seeing here right that that's if
that's the Federal Bureau of control or
that they've contained that at least
this is the it's outdoors which didn't
happen in the first game I guess the
containment failed so yeah super
exciting in my opinion I think that's
great happy to have more remedy games
happy to have them with a bigger budget
um I wish the best for that team of very
creative people next up is about Sonic
Frontiers uh and this story says Sonic
Frontiers director says he's taking
feedback seriously Mario Kishimoto says
Sonic team is taking feedback from
players and critics and I spoke to
somebody on the team there and they
basically said the exact same thing to
me
I don't want to share more details of
that in case
um
I would be getting them in trouble
because it was not an official comment
but they did tell me that they were
looking really closely at the feedback
and appreciated the feedback or any of
the negative feedback on Sonic Frontiers
and that it I get the impression that
this is uh
from that conversation and from some of
these conversations surrounding it
that we should expect a sequel to
Frontiers and that we should expect the
sequel to really really build on the
positive things about Frontiers which is
awesome so the article which is from
videogameschronicle.com says the
director of Sonic Frontiers has
suggested that there are still some
areas in which the game can be improved
Mario Kishimoto posted a tweet on Friday
in which he stated that the Sonic team
was studying the feedback from players
and critics and taking that into account
Kishimoto also like in Sonic Frontiers
is released to a global play test
suggesting that he doesn't consider the
game's release to be the end of the
story which I don't love people
shouldn't have to pay to play test your
game but I digress I'm sorry I haven't
contacted you until now because we've
been busy since the release date
Kishimoto tweeted same that's why that
wasn't an episode of the show last week
God of War Ragnarok released on the same
day I feel you I'm relieved that the
release date has arrived and that the
game seems to have reached everyone
safely we are checking out the opinions
of critics and players as you've pointed
out there are still areas where we are
not quite there yet and we will take
this seriously like a global play test
okay if that's what he said that's not
so bad the way it's phrased up here
makes it sound like he thinks it is a
global play test but they did say
likened it to and I feel like they're
freezing here
is okay said we will take this seriously
like a global play test kishimoto's last
tweet before this was the day before
Sonic Frontiers was released in which he
suggested that Frontier wait it is front
Frontiers isn't it there is an s
okay thank God and when she suggested
that Frontier would change the Sonic
game and would be a major milestone in
the long history of Sonic games it's
different do I think it's changed the
Sonic game probably not so much without
spoiling anything the game's
post-credits scene also implies that
story isn't over yet suggesting a sequel
may come at some point okay well that
aligns I haven't finished the game but
that aligns with what I believe from
conversations that I've had with
multiple people that's probably that the
gross credits is probably why they're
even comfortable saying anything at all
to me to be honest vgc's Sonic Frontiers
Review called the game the kick up the
backside 3D Sonic has been crying out
for describing it as a truly
accomplished effort that hits a lot more
than it misses and the reviews were way
more positive than I expected because
when I played the game I played it at
um games week I don't even know what
it's called Summer game Fest Games Week
Jeff what is it called came first
and it was very buggy
um not actually even because of the game
itself but because of the the
performance of the way they would trying
to run the bill it looked terrible it
crashed you had an Xbox controller with
PlayStation inputs or vice versa so it
wasn't showing the right controller
prompts on screen and it made it
difficult to preview because it was just
in a messy shape for that build and
that's what a lot of my negative
sentiment was I still didn't love the
open world but it seems like reviewers
are a lot more positive on that than I
was from the very small amount of time
that I got to play it so I was always
open-minded about it so very happy to
hear that but I also have played very
little of it so I don't feel like I can
comment on if my opinion on that changed
at this rate so yeah ultimately
um it's just very nice when I believe
when somebody says this right I feel
like we we see people in the games
industry all the time say
we heard you hey we listen hey gamer the
next story I'm pulling from reset era
um resetera I don't know which I don't
love but it was also the only place that
I could find a transcript of this
conversation so this is from Tiger of
course who said there's been a lot of
discussion on the types of games that
subscription services like Game Pass
might allow or encourage or incentivize
so I found this interesting as part of a
discussion with Rob zackney on this
Tuesday's Waypoint radio obsidian's Josh
Sawyer made it clear that pentiment a
small scale single-player narrative
Adventure set in 16th century Germany
would not exist exist if it were not for
Game Pass I never would have proposed
making pentiment without Game Pass like
I literally just wouldn't have done it I
just don't think it would have been
possible which I'm pretty sure I I wrote
word for word when I previewed the game
I was like this is a Game Pass play and
I think I said it on the episode of
playwatch listen where it was so clear
to me that it was a Game Pass game made
by a team of 13 it's very unusual it's
very Niche a really unique art style a
very specific historical setting that a
lot of people aren't going to be
educated on but they also explicitly
said
um when we were doing our preview
that they expected people who didn't
even like games necessarily to like this
game and that you didn't need to know
how to play games to play it which is
definitely true and that it should be
easy to play
um and that to me is like that's a game
pause game
you want people who are just using their
phones who are streaming through xcloud
and have Game Pass to play pentiment for
the rest of this it goes on to say the
old mentality of Publishers and
developers is generally focused on
larger Investments with higher Roi which
is return on investment and that's not
the point of this environment in this
ecosystem Game Pass is the only way in
which I conceive a pentiment being
viable for my own sake making a game so
different I've completely shifted my
thinking for pentiment it's so unusual
so Niche it's for a small audience and
as long as that audience is into it
that's fine and they also went on to say
that grounded doesn't
um apply here granted was something that
we've been wanting to do with studio for
a while make a survival game and we
already had buy-in from upper management
at obsidian so it was uh well underway
before the Microsoft deal and the reason
that I consider this to be uh good news
is because pentiment is really unusual
but from what I've played I also think
it's fantastic and the fact that
something as weird and alerting and
dense and smart as pentiment wouldn't
exist if not for Game Pass is a huge win
giving you a pretty extreme review here
because the IGN review was a 10 out of
10 but to give you a bit of a synopsis
of someone who's I assume finished the
game I hope so lyanna Hafer the IGN
review pentiment says it's been an age
since I felt so captivated by such a
simple Adventure game as pentiment
arousing subtly pays detective Thrill is
set in the late medieval Bavarian
Countryside the storybook art style
inspired by colorful manuscripts of the
era is downright enthralling while the
gameplay basically consists of looking
around for Clues questioning townspoke
and trying to draw your own conclusions
about the evidence you find that
minimalist approach works excellently
for the rich and complex story pentiment
tells and even based on the few hours
that I have played a pentiment it does
feel complex it feels really smart it
feels like a game that is inviting me to
make decisions that don't actually
Impact gameplay right like what I'm
trying to express there is that it it
feels like a game that's saying Hey I
want you to think about this when you
leave this today I don't want you to
think about this because I told you
where the next marker was or because I
told you you needed to kill something it
really draws more out of you um in a way
that I think is very impressive but also
I would not recommend the game to
everyone there's no way that pentiment
is for everyone that's the beauty of
Game Pass and services like Game Pass in
general it means that you can try it and
if you don't like it it didn't cost you
anything speaking of very good games
coming out God of War Ragnarok is
already the biggest launch in the
franchise's history it will be the
fourth number one for the series
gfk predicts so I believe this is
specific to the UK
but the story says this is from games
industry.biz go to what Ragnarok has got
off to a massive start in the UK
according to charts firm gfk it is on
course to be the fourth game in the
series to top the UK box charts The Firm
has said there have previously been 12
God of War games released in the UK
including six main releases two portable
games and a series of Collections and
remakes first game was released in July
2005 on PS2 and debuted at number five
one of just two times that a main god of
war title didn't debut at number one the
second game in the series released two
years later May 2007 also on PS2 and
after the PS3 was released reached
number one the franchise moved to PS3
for God of War 3 in March match match
2010 and also topped the chats once
again fourth Mainline title God of War
ascension arrived three years later but
was held off number one by the Tomb
Raider reboot from Crystal Dynamics
series really stepped it up for 2018's
God of War reboot on Playstation 4. it
became the best seller at that time in
terms of week one sales and also
lifetime sales for this franchise in
2018 God of War ranked it number five by
units and revenue on so only formats now
at the launch of gun or Ragnarok and
based on box sales alone it will become
the biggest God of War title launch in
the UK which I think we can probably
extrapolate to assume it's reflective of
the rest of the world I would think got
a while Ragnarok will debut at number
one and is the first gen title in the
series day one physical sales were
already greater than any other full week
launch sales but other titles in this
franchise so the reason I I consider
this to be good news um outside of my
own personal bias obviously is that
every time a game like this succeeds I
take it as a huge win for all of the
facets of the industry that say single
player games are dead the more we have a
killer single player narrative driven
game which is the kind of games that I
grew up playing that I love playing that
I will never stop loving playing and I
know there are a lot of other people
like me who feel the same way if you
don't that's fine nobody's asking you to
it's okay don't you don't need to I like
a story and some fun combat personally
then it just reinforces that this can
continue to happen which is a thing that
I think is important in the industry
where there are several fears quite
frequently about single player games
dying out I have said for years that I
don't think Sony will ever stop making
these uh huge Blockbuster single player
experiences because that's what gets you
to buy a PS5 or a PS4 and that it is one
of the cases in which I consider
exclusivity to be a positive is that the
exclusivity forces these things to be of
extremely high quality because they're
to sell Hardware
at least that's how I see it in my head
I don't know if that's factually correct
but it's just awesome news it's awesome
news for the people like me who like
single player games you'll love to see
it next up speaking of single player
games that I really like The Witcher
another just so many tweets related to
The Witcher lately so many news bits
related to The Witcher I'll take it at
which game on Twitter said The Next Gen
update for The Witcher 3 wild Hunt is
coming on December 14th free for
everyone who already owns the game for
more details and gameplay reveal a tune
in to Red streams next week on twitch.tv
project red which I will thank you but
just really nice to finally get an
update on something that I feel like a
lot of people have been waiting for for
a very long time and last but not least
the nominees have been announced
for the game awards so I thought that we
would just look over them because it's
always fun it's always a fun time of
year
um I have not actually looked over these
though obviously I know that God of War
Ragnarok is nominated so we have Game of
the Year play tale Requiem which I think
is fantastic Elden ring which I think is
fantastic God of War Ragnarok Horizon
forbidden West also mind-blowing maybe
one of the best looking games in the
world stray is a kind of surprising one
but I'm very glad to see it and
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 I'm super glad to
see the others here make sense at least
these four were almost guaranteed right
because of the kind of games they are
because of how big they are and how
emotional they are and yes I maintain
that Elden ring is emotional it is a
game that that gets you hooked on
frustration and difficulty even the way
that it it channels difficulty and focus
is on an emotional level stray I loved I
loved stray and to be clear I don't care
about cats I don't even really like cats
very much because I'm allergic to them
they're all most of the devil and I only
say that because I've seen people be
like oh I know they got nominated
because cat game no no no no no
strangers are really really really good
game it executes on what it intends to
so well it really resonated with me it's
got beautiful design a really really
well crafted world I really like
straight but um I could see that not
ending up here Xenoblade Chronicles 3 is
the one that I feel the most positively
about because it's very well deserved
but is a less popular game so it was
always up in the air if it would
actually end up on this list or not
there are other games that I would put
here personally sifu is easily in my top
five games of the year I love sifu like
adore it
um but of course it's never supposed to
be reflective of everybody's opinion
she's just an aggregate don't take it
too seriously if your favorite thing is
or is not there but then I play
Chronicle stream I'm just really happy
to see it I think it's it's well
deserved and I'm glad it's getting the
respect it deserves in my opinion best
game Direction game direction is a
really interesting one too interesting
here Elden ring God of War Ragnarok
Horizon forbidden West immortality and
stray can't argue with any of these
either
um what I consider game direction to be
and I have been on the voting board for
the game awards before so I have voted
the games for this before
um direction is uh how all of the parts
tie the thing together
it's so funny that they're gone before
Ragnarok are like the head's greatest
okay yeah it's it's how uh how all the
pieces fit together to a cohesive Vision
something that is designed in every way
to funnel towards the same point and I
do think that pretty much every game
here deserves it though I didn't like
immortality which really sucks because I
love their other games I just didn't
Vibe with immortality huge problem but I
deserves to be there too for sure like
no doubt best narrative playtale Requiem
Elden ring that's interesting I don't
necessarily think that's wrong either
but that's unexpected which is cool it
makes it cool God of War Ragnarok
Horizon forbidden West and immortality
for outstanding storytelling and
narrative development in a game yeah if
it's outstanding storytelling and
narrative development eldering and
immortality one thousand percent they
stand out in the way that they tell the
stories they're very unique in their
approach to storytelling and narrative
development best art Direction eldering
God of War right now
and stray you gotta have sifu here
best art direction and you don't have
sifu I would have thought that was a
shoe in seafood's so stylish again
people be having opinions I I think
scorn's a really fun pick for that so
distinct best score and music play tale
Requiem Elden ring God of War Ragnarok
metal hell singer Xenoblade Chronicles 3
metal Helsing is the the Oddball out
there that is so [ __ ] cool like such
a unique game in terms of of Music in
school very much outstanding in my
opinion but yes all fantastic at what
they do there too first audio design
Call of Duty always very good elderly
God of War Ragnarok Grand Tetris most
seven and Horizon forbidden West best
performance Ashley Birch who's Eloy in
Horizon forbidden West the playtail
Requiem of Charlotte Bernie got a
Ragnarok Christopher Judge immortality
men engage and got our Ragnarok Sunny
subject it's kind of a shame not to see
Danielle here obviously bias but uh
Danielle who plays Freya I think her
character is incredible and so it's kind
of a bummer games for impact a memoir
blue I really liked the memo blue I
actually have um if you haven't seen
that game I have a full playthrough of
that game here on my channel and I did
it did get me emotionally it was really
sweet as does Falls I still haven't
finished citizen sleeper I was a teenage
exocolonist hindsight and endling
Extinction is over best ongoing Apex
Legends Destiny 2 Final Fantasy fortnite
gentian impact on good choices best
Indie this is where I'm gonna end it
because there I mean there are a lot of
categories we're only on 10 but I was
only going to do 10. best Indie we have
Cult of the Lamb neon white sifu stray
and tunic I love every single one of
these games every single game on this
list is fantastic these are some of my
favorite games of the year just in the
Indie section and if you haven't played
these games please do tunic is basically
like
um cute Zelda and it's harder very
similar to Zelda and that you get your
sword and you get your Shield uh but
really really precise combat it's a very
frustrating game really sweet open world
with very minimal dialogue if any really
inspires Adventure it looks cute because
it is cute but it's also very punishing
love it stray again the the cool cat
game that is um effectively a puzzle
game where you're learning about a world
it is more of a story about a world than
anything else sifu is I guess an action
game where you fight stuff but you have
to die to kind of get better at fighting
stuff and then you would restart the
whole level so that you can try and get
through the whole level without ever
dying so the first time you might die so
many times you can't finish the level
because uh once you get past a certain
age in sifu you will die and you'll have
to like it'll it'll quit you out but
then by the end you can get through
levels without dying at all and it seems
nuts because of how many times you got
your butt kicked at first it's about
learning levels learning the game
learning how to get through these levels
and starting to feel like a boss it's
basically like speedrunning gamified but
it's really stylish feels so good to
play genuinely that game is absolutely
in my top five I love sifu so much I had
so much fun playing it speaking of
speedrunning neon white very unique very
weird game that um I think would
probably like be off-putting to some
people in how anime it is but it is
effectively all about speedrunning as
well and finding secrets in these little
platforming levels where you have these
different guns that do different things
and every single level that you finish
it gives you your friend's fastest times
and it has a very quick restart level
button so you're going to want to go
through over and over and over again to
try and beat Andy Cortez specifically I
didn't ever beat him the unwipe very
unique very addictive Cult of the Lamb I
mean they're all unique that's the thing
Cult of the Lamb is again in my top five
I reckon love it it's a resource
management and construction game I guess
um I'll uh Animal Crossing but every
night uh you go out and you fight a
bunch of spooky stuff in the woods and
you find new members to recruit to your
cult so that you can get like more cult
points so that you can build more stuff
in the cult so it's Animal Crossing in a
way with the twist of it being again a
very cute lamb but you're in a cult so
it's funny and dark and humorous while
also having really fast flashy combat
with some really cool decision making
and definitely getting that Resource
Management type game look into you also
I love the soundtrack the score the
music and Cult of the Lamb
all right uh that's only for people who
didn't know about these games before I
assume a lot of you do and I will leave
it there everybody thank you for
watching another episode of good gaming
news I'll see you all next week
[Music]